Les voy a hablar acerca de algo que está en uno de mis libros
que espero resonará con otras cosas que ustedes han escuchado,
e intentaré hacer algunas conexiones yo mismo, en caso de que ustedes las pierdan.
Quiero empezar con lo que llamo el "dogma oficial".
¿El dogma oficial de qué?
El dogma oficial de todas las sociedades industriales occidentales.
Y el dogma oficial dice así:
Si estamos interesados en maximizar el bienestar de nuestros ciudadanos,
la manera de hacerlo es maximizar la libertad individual.
La razón de esto es tanto que la libertad en sí misma es buena,
como valiosa, loable y esencial a los seres humanos.
Y porque si la gente tiene libertad,
entonces cada uno de nosotros puede actuar por nuestra cuenta para
hacer las cosas que maximizarán nuestro bienestar
y nadie tendrá que decidir en nuestro nombre.
La forma de maximizar libertad es maximizando la elección.
Entre más posibilidades tenga la gente, más libertad tendrá
y entre más libertad tenga,
más bienestar tendrán.
Esta idea, pienso, está tan profundamente integrada en el abasto de agua
que a nadie se le ocurriría cuestionarlo.
Y también está profundamente integrado en nuestras vidas.
Les daré algunos ejemplos de cómo el progreso moderno lo ha hecho posible para nosotros
Este es mi supermercado. No es tan grande.
Quisiera decir unas palabras acerca de los aderezos de ensalada.
Hay 175 aderezos de ensalada en mi supermercado.
Eso si no contamos los 10 diferentes tipos de aceite de oliva extra virgen
y los 12 vinagres balsámicos que pueden comprar.
para que hagan su propia gran variedad de aderezos,
en el caso remoto de que ninguna de las 175 que ofrece la tienda les guste.
Y así es como es en el supermercado.
Y luego vayan a la tienda de electrodomésticos para ver los sistemas estereofónicos,
bocinas, reproductores de CD, de cintas, sintonizador, amplificador.
Y esto en una sola tienda de electrodomésticos,
tienen esta cantidad de sistemas estereofónicos.
Podemos construir seis y medio millones de sistemas de estéreo diferentes
con los componentes que se ofrecen en una sola tienda.
Reconozcamos que hay mucho para elegir.
En otros campos, el mundo de las comunicaciones.
Hubo una época, cuando era niño,
cuando uno podía obtener cualquier tipo de servicio telefónico que quisiera,
siempre y cuando viniera de Ma Bell.
Uno rentaba el teléfono. No lo compraba.
Una consecuencia de esto, por cierto, es que el teléfono nunca se descomponía
Esos tiempos ya se fueron.
Ahora tenemos una casi ilimitada variedad de aparatos telefónicos,
especialmente en el mundo de los celulares.
Estos son los celulares del futuro.
Mi favorito es el de en medio,
con reproductor MP3, rasuradora de pelos de la nariz, encendedor para creme brulee.
Y si por si acaso no lo han visto en su tienda todavía,
les puedo asegurar que pronto algún día lo tendrá.
Y lo que esto hace es
conducir a la gente a entrar a las tiendas haciéndose esta pregunta.
¿Y saben cuál es ahora la respuesta a esta pregunta?
La respuesta es "No."
No es posible comprar un celular que no haga demasiado.
Así, en otros aspectos de la vida que son mucho más significativos que comprar cosas,
la misma explosión de posibilidades es cierta.
Servicios de salud, ya no es más el caso en Estados Unidos
cuando uno iba al doctor y el doctor le decía a uno qué hacer.
En su lugar, uno va al doctor
y el doctor dice, bueno, podríamos hacer A ó B.
A tiene estos beneficios y estos riesgos
B tiene estos beneficios y estos riesgos ¿qué quiere hacer?
Y uno dice: "Doc ¿qué debo hacer?"
Y el doc dice: A tiene estos beneficios y estos riesgos y B tiene estos beneficios y estos riesgos.
¿Qué quiere hacer?
Y uno dice: "Si usted fuera yo, Doc, qué haría?"
Y el doc dice: "Pero yo no soy usted."
Y el resultado es lo que llamamos "autonomía del paciente."
lo cual suena como algo bueno.
Pero lo que en realidad ocurre es un traslado de la carga y la responsabilidad
de tomar decisiones de alguien que sabe algo,
a saber el doctor,
a alguien que no sabe nada y que probablemente está enfermo
y que no está en la mejor forma para tomar decisiones,
a saber el paciente.
Existe una enorme mercadotecnia de los medicamentos recetados
para personas como ustedes y yo,
que si lo piensan, no tiene sentido en absoluto,
porque no podemos comprarlos sin recetas.
¿Por qué nos los mercadean si no los podemos comprar?
La respuesta es que esperan que llamemos a nuestros doctores el día siguiente
y pidamos que nos cambie la receta.
Algo tan drástico como nuestra identidad
se ha vuelto ahora una cuestión de elegir,
como lo indica esta diapositiva.
No heredamos una identidad, tenemos que inventarla.
Y nos reinventarnos con la frecuencia con la que queremos.
Y esto significa que cada día cuando nos despertamos en la mañana,
tenemos que decidir que clase de persona queremos ser.
Con respecto al matrimonio y a la familia,
hubo un tiempo que la suposición por omisión que casi todos tenían
es que te casabas tan pronto como podías,
luego empezabas a tener hijos tan pronto como podías.
La única elección real era quien,
no cuando y no lo que harías después.
Hoy en día, todo está más a nuestra dispocicion.
Doy clases con mucha fortuna a estudiantes inteligentes,
y les asigno 20% menos trabajo de lo que solía hacer.
Y no es porque sean menos listos,
y tampoco porque sean menos diligentes,
Es porque están preocupados, preguntándose,
¿Debo casarme o no? ¿Debo casarme ahora?
¿O debo casarme después? ¿Primero los hijos o la carrera?
Todas estas son preguntas avasalladoras.
Y las tienen que contestar,
aun cuando hagan o no todo el trabajo que les asigno
y no obtengan buenas calificaciones en sus cursos.
En efecto tienen que hacerlo. Estas son preguntas importantes a responder.
Trabajo, somos benditos, como lo apuntaba Carl,
con la tecnología que nos permite
trabajar cada minuto del día desde cualquier lugar del planeta
excepto el Hotel Randolph.
(Risas)
Existe una esquina, por cierto
pero no se los voy a contar, donde el WiFi funciona.
Y no se los voy a decir porque yo quiero usarlo.
Lo que esto significa, esta increíble libertad de eleccion
que tenemos con respecto al trabajo, es que tenemos que tomar una decisión,
una y otra vez y otra vez
acerca de si debemos o no trabajar.
Podemos ir a ver a nuestros hijos jugar futbol,
y tener nuestro celular en una cadera,
y nuestro Blackberry en la otra,
y nuestra laptop, supuestamente, en nuestro regazo.
Incluso si los tuviéramos apagados,
cada minuto en que estemos viendo a nuestro hijo mutilar un partido de futbol,
nos estaremos preguntando,
"¿Debo contestar el celular?"
"¿Debo responder el correo? ¿Debo hacer el borrador de la carta?"
Incluso si la respuesta a la pregunta es "no",
esto ciertamente hará la experiencia del partido de futbol de tu hijo
muy diferente de lo que hubiera sido.
Así que en cualquier lado donde miremos,
cosas grandes y pequeñas, cosas materiales y cosas del estilo de vida,
la vida es una cuestión de elegir.
Y el mundo al que estabamos acostumbrados a vivir era así.
Es decir, teníamos algunas elecciones,
pero no todas era una cuestión de elegir,
Pero el mundo en el que vivimos ahora se ve así.
¿Y la pregunta es, son buenas o malas noticias?
La respuesta es sí.
(Risas)
Todos sabemos lo bueno de esto,
así que voy a hablar de lo malo.
Toda esto de elegir tiene dos efectos,
dos efectos negativos en la gente.
Un efecto, paradójicamente,
es que produce parálisis más que liberación.
Con tantas opciones a elegir,
la gente encuentra simplemente difícil hacer la elección.
Les voy a dar un ejemplo drástico de esto,
un estudio que se hizo de inversiones para planes de retiro voluntario.
Un colega mío tuvo acceso a los registros de inversión de Vanguard,
el gigante de fondos de inversión
de cerca de un millón de empleados en cerca de 2,000 diferentes lugares de trabajo.
Lo que ella encontró es que
por cada 10 fondos de inversión que el patrón ofrecía,
la tasa de participación bajaba dos por ciento.
Si se ofrecían 50 fondos, 10 por ciento menos de empleados participaban.
que si sólo se ofrecían cinco ¿por qué?
Porque con 50 fondos a escoger,
es tan difícil decidir cuál fondo escoger.
que simplemente lo pospones para mañana.
Y entonces mañana y mañana
y mañana y mañana,
y por supuesto mañana nunca llega.
Entendamos que esto no sólo significa que
la gente tendrá que comer comida de perros cuando se retire
porque no tendrán dinero suficiente para ahorrar
también significa que tomar una decisión es tan difícil
que dejan pasar una importante beneficio monetario de su empleador.
Al no participar, dejan pasar tanto como 5000 dólares al año
de su empleador, quien felizmente se beneficia.
Así que la parálisis es una consecuencia de tener demasiadas elecciones.
Y pienso que esto hace que el mundo se vea así.
(Risas)
En verdad uno quiere tomar la decisión correcta si es por toda la eternidad ¿cierto?
Uno no quiere elegir el fondo erróneo, incluso el aderezo incorrecto.
Entonces este es un efecto. El segundo efecto es que
aun cuando logremos rebasar la parálisis y elegir,
acabamos menos satisfechos con el resultado de la elección
de lo que estaríamos si hubiésemos tenido menor opciones para elegir.
Y hay varias razones para esto.
Una de ellas es que con tantos tipos diferentes de aderezos para elegir,
si compras uno y no es perfecto y, bueno ¿cuál aderezo lo es?
Es fácil imaginar que pudiste haber realizado una elección diferente
que hubiese sido mejor. Lo que ocurre es que
esta alternativa imaginada te induce a lamentar la decisión que hiciste,
y este remordimiento le resta a la satisfacción que obtienes de la decisión que hiciste,
aun cuando la decisión haya sido buena.
Entre más opciones existan, es más fácil lamentarlo todo,
hace que la opción que elegiste sea decepcionante.
Segundo, lo que los economistas llaman costos de oportunidad.
Dan Gilbert recalcó esto esta mañana
al hablar de como la manera que valoramos las cosas
varia de acuerdo a lo que las comparamos.
Bien, cuando existen muchas alternativas a considerar,
es fácil imaginar los aspectos atractivos
de las alternativas que rechazas,
que te dejan menos satisfecho con la alternativa que has escogido.
Les pongo un ejemplo. Para aquellos de ustedes que no sean neoyorquinos, una disculpa.
(Risas)
Aquí está lo que se supone que estás pensando.
Tenemos una pareja en los Hamptons.
Una propiedad muy cara.
Playa fabulosa, día hermoso. Lo tienen todo para ellos.
¿Qué podría haber mejor? "Pues, maldita sea, "
está pensando este tipo, "Es agosto,
todo mundo en el vecindario de Manhattan está fuera.
Podría estacionarme justo en frente de mi edificio."
Pasa dos semanas atormentado por la idea
de que se está perdiendo la oportunidad, día tras día, de tener un buen lugar para estacionarse.
Los costos de oportunidad sustraen de la satisfacción que obtenemos de lo que elegimos,
incluso cuando lo que elegimos es estupendo.
Y entre más opciones existan a considerar,
más aspectos atractivos de estas opciones
se reflejarán en nosotros como costos de oportunidad.
Otro ejemplo.
Esta caricatura tiene varios puntos.
Hace también observaciones acerca de vivir en el momento,
y probablemente sobre hacer las cosas despacio.
Pero un punto que hace es que en el momento en que elegimos una cosa,
estás eligiendo no hacer otras cosas.
Y esas otras cosas tienen muchos aspectos atractivos,
que harán que lo que estás haciendo sea menos atractivo.
Tercero: escala de expectativas.
Me dí cuenta de esto cuando fui a reemplazar unos jeans.
Visto jeans casi todo el tiempo.
Y hubo una época en que los jeans eran de un solo tipo,
y los comprabas, y te quedaban horrible,
y eran increíblemente incómodos,
y si los vestías el tiempo suficiente y los lavabas las suficientes veces,
empezaban a sentirse bien.
Así que fui a reemplazar mis jeans después de años y años de usar los viejos,
y dije: "Quiero unos jeans de esta talla."
Y el vendedor de la tienda dice:
"¿Los quiere ajustados, justos, o sueltos?
¿Los quiere con bragueta de botones o cierre? ¿Deslavados a piedra o en ácido?
¿Los quiere aflojados?
Los quiere de corte recto, estrecho, bla, bla bla..." y así se siguió.
Se me cayó la quijada y cuando me recuperé, le dije,
"Quiero del tipo que solía ser el único tipo que había."
(Risas)
El vendedor no tenía idea de lo que era,
así que me pase una hora probando todos estos pantalones,
y salí de la tienda -la verdad sea dicha- con el jean que mejor me ha quedado.
Mejoré. Toda esta elección me permitió mejorar.
Pero me sentí peor.
¿Por qué? Escribí todo un libro para intentar explicármelo a mí mismo.
La razón por la que me sentí peor es que,
con todas estas opciones disponibles,
mis expectativas acerca de un par de jeans se fueron para arriba.
Yo tenía expectativas bajas.
No tenía expectativas particulares cuando sólo había un tipo.
Ahora que vienen en 100 diferentes, maldita sea,
uno de ellos ha de ser perfecto.
Y lo que obtuve fue bueno, pero no fue perfecto.
Así que comparé lo que obtuve con lo que esperaba,
y lo que obtuve fue decepcionante en comparación a lo que esperaba.
Agregar opciones a la vida de la gente
inevitablemente incrementa las expectativas que las personas tienen
sobre lo bueno que esas opciones tienen.
Y lo que eso va a producir es menos satisfacción con los resultados,
aun cuando los resultados sean buenos.
Nadie en el mundo del marketing sabe esto
Porque si lo supieran, ustedes no sabrían nada acerca de esto.
La verdad es más parecida a esto.
(Risas)
La razón de que todo era mejor antes cuando todo era peor
es que cuando todo era peor,
era en efecto posible que gente tuviera experiencias que fuesen sorpresas placenteras.
En la actualidad, en el mundo en que vivimos, nosotros los ciudadanos industrializados, afluentes,
con perfección de la expectativa,
lo mejor que puedes aspirar es que las cosas sean tan buenas como esperabas que lo fueran.
Nunca recibirás una sorpresa placentera
porque tus expectativas, mis expectativas, se fueran por arriba del techo.
El secreto de la felicidad -- que es lo que todos buscamos --
el secreto de la felicidad es tener bajas expectativas.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Quiero decirles -- un corto aporte autobiográfico --
que estoy casado con una mujer
que es realmente bastante maravillosa.
No me pudo haber ido mejor. No me acomode.
Aunque acomodarse no siempre es algo malo.
Finalmente, una consecuencia de comprar un mal par de pantalones de mezclilla
cuando sólo existe un tipo a comprar
es que cuando estás insatisfecho y te preguntas por qué,
quién es el responsable, la respuesta es clara.
El mundo es responsable ¿qué puedes hacer?
Cuando existen cientos estilos diferentes de jeans disponibles,
y compras uno que te decepciona,
y te preguntas por qué, quién es el responsable?
Es de la igualmente claro que la respuesta a la pregunta eres tú.
Pudiste haberlo hecho mejor.
Con un centenar de tipos diferentes de jeasn en despliegue,
no hay excusa al fracaso.
Entonces cuando la gente toma decisiones,
incluso cuando los resultados de las decisiones sean buenos,
se sienten decepcionados por ellos,
se culpan así mismos.
La depresión clínica ha explotado en el mundo industrial en la última generación.
Yo creo que un contribuyente significativo, no el único, pero significativo
a esta explosión de la depresión al igual que del suicidio,
es que la gente tiene experiencias que son decepcionantes
porque sus estándares son muy altos.
Y cuando tienen que explicarse estas experiencias a sí mismos,
piensan que son culpables.
Entonces el resultado neto es que en general lo estamos haciendo mejor, objetivamente,
pero nos sentimos peor.
Así que déjenme que les recuerde.
Este es el dogma oficial, el que todos tomamos como verdadero,
y que sea del todo falso. No es verdadero.
No cabe duda que algo de eleccion es mejor que nada,
pero tener más elecciones no es mejor que sólo tener algunas cuantas
Existe un monto mágico. No sé cuál es;
pero me siento lo suficiente confiado para afirmar que hace mucho que rebasamos el punto
donde esas opciones mejoraban nuestro bienestar.
Ahora, como una cuestión de políticas -- ya casi termino --
como una cuestión de políticas, la cosa a pensar es esta.
Lo que permite toda estas elecciones en las sociedades industriales es la afluencia material.
Hay muchos lugares en el mundo,
y hemos escuchado acerca de varios de ellos,
donde su problema no es que tengan demasiadas opciones.
Su problema es que tienen demasiado pocas.
Así que esto de lo que hablo es un problema peculiar
de sociedades occidentales, afluentes, modernas.
Y lo que es frustrante y exasperante es esto:
Steve Levitt nos habló ayer acerca de cómo
no sirven estos asientos para niños caros y difíciles de instalar. Es un desperdicio de dinero.
Lo que les estoy diciendo es que estas opciones complicadas y caras,
no es simplemente que no sirvan,
de hecho lastiman.
Nos hacen sentir peor.
Si algo de lo que permite que la gente en nuestras sociedades tenga tantas opciones
se trasladara a sociedades en que la gente tiene muy pocas opciones,
no sólo se mejoraría la vida de esas personas,
sino también la nuestra mejoraría.
Esto es lo que los economistas llaman óptimo de Pareto.
La redistribución del ingreso nos beneficia a todos -- no sólo a la gente pobre --
debido a cómo todo este exceso de opciones nos infestan.
Para concluir. Se supone que leyeron esta caricatura,
y, siendo una persona sofisticada, digamos,
"¡Oh!¿qué sabe este pez?
Bueno nada es posible en esta pecera."
Imaginación pobre, visión miope del mundo,
y esa es la forma en que lo leí la primera vez.
Entre más lo pienso, sin embargo,
más me acerco a la opinión de que este pez sabe algo.
Porque la verdad de las cosas es que
si rompes esta pecera para que todo sea posible,
no tienes libertad; tienes parálisis.
Si rompes esta pecera para que todo sea posible,
reduces tu satisfacción.
Incrementas la parálisis y disminuyes la satisfacción.
Todos necesitamos una pecera.
Esta ciertamente es muy limitada
quizás incluso para el pez, ciertamente para nosotros.
Pero la ausencia de alguna pecera metafórica es una receta para la miseria,
y, yo sospecho, para el desastre.
Muchas gracias
(Aplausos)